i'm not surprised i i think the um
steps that sadiq khan took
to say
you don't have the trust and confidence
of communities
especially after the charing cross
operation hotend revelations and that
had a specific resonance with me because
i served at charon cross police station
between 2000 2004 and i know you'll have
small numbers of officers who might have
those thoughts but you have to be
proactive as a supervisor to
detect them and to s and direct them
and to sanction them if need be but like
everything
i couldn't believe what i read and i can
understand it was that the end of a
litany of issues that
crusader dick has allowed to manifest
during her watch and she had to go
why do you think she was unable to to
tackle this this rotten culture within
the met what was she doing wrong
well um i remember when she she was
appointed in 2017 i actually welcomed
her appointment despite the issues
around john charles menendez shooting at
stockwell
and
and i thought she'd be a breath of fresh
air because she was part of mcpherson
and all the recommendations 20 years
earlier so i really thought she was
going to bring in a real ethical
leadership a real understanding of
accountability and transparency and not
double down on what's going on but in in
in the end we saw that she was saying
well she doesn't recognize institutional
sexism she doesn't recognize
institutional racism and in fact she
started become like a blocker she was um
part of the problem or part of the
solution and then
she
during um the black lives matter issues
and and the george floyd murder she says
she's not going to investigate the
stephen lawrence case anymore and
that has such a massive impact on not
only on the lawrence family but in the
wider black community
and that's when trust and confidence
went down
severely and
remember the cornerstone of policing is
trust and confidence if you don't have
the trust and confidence of communities
then you are literally
not policing with authority and you
can't arrest your way out of the problem
you can't stop and search about a
problem you've got to work in
partnership with the communities and the
black community in itself saw trust and
confidence at this lowest ebb and so
she had to go because she will not
instill that confidence back in those
communities
but but she herself uh claimed to be uh
doing all that she could this morning
she said i have absolutely no intention
of going and i believe that i am and
have been actually for the last five
years leading a real transformation
in the met so
what had she put in place
that's a very good question i mean if
you just look at the sarah everard case
and
they knew a police officer was involved
and eventually gets charged and
convicted six months later at his
conviction
they they suggested the way in which you
help women and girls to
challenge officers is to get them to
pass on their radio and speak to them on
uh speak to the control room or go to a
bus and and try and speak to the bus
drivers they can use the radio i mean
that was so inept i thought to myself is
that all you can come up with six months
after the the murder of sarah everard
and and and those are sort of things
that you think is not going to instill
confidence in people and and and if if
you look at all the people that have
come out
a lot of the women are saying we we are
glad to see her go and and that's the
irony the first female commissioner
seemed to have created so much barriers
for her own gender
it begs belief
why do you think she had a a tin ear was
she just not really
in touch with what was happening in in
the the roots of the the organization i
think she was in so much denial and
she's brought into a certain type of a
culture that she couldn't see it
in a way because i i've known chris she
told me to call her chris 28 years ago
and i've done a lot of work with her
highlighted in my autobiography closing
ranks so i'm not just being familiar
just for the sake of it but i remember
her um talking about she doesn't
recognize institutional racism 20 odd
years ago she was involved in mcpherson
and recommendations and everything that
went with it
so for her to say she doesn't recognize
it because nothing has changed the whole
the same issues of recruitment retention
progression are still there the issues
of stop and search and the impact it has
on young black men
and we've seen on social media time and
time again of very very aggressive
arrests she would never really say we
have a problem we're going to do
something about it and
ensure that it's sustainable and they're
not going to hold back on being you know
popular and and
ingratiate themselves with the culture
and i think that's what she did she
seemed to say well listen i'm going to
defend the culture like it's my child
and whoever's trying to criticize it
she's going to protect them and and and
not allow um anyone to criticize and so
she became as i said a barrier
of accountability and transparency
instead of saying we have an open
organization and it's a service and we
want to work in partnership with all
communities
there are very many uh instances in
which she's been criticized many cases
you mentioned one john charles de
menezes extinction rebellion uh sarah
everard we know nicole henry and bieber
smallman daniel morgan
do you think that she was allowed to
remain in post far too long
i think so i i really i i cannot see how
um
another officer especially a male
officer would have been given that
amount of
flexibility i don't think they would
have got the job in the first place
she's a very capable person and it
saddens me that she didn't deliver as i
know she could have and i i know
um there's a lot of people in the
organization be sad for it but i really
believe there are
really strong leaders not just in london
but in in police services across the
country who can do an amazing job to to
really transform the met because the met
is the largest organization police
service in the country and it needs a
certain amount of ethical leadership and
a real understanding of the communities
they serve and i really l i'd like to
think this change will be an improvement
that everyone will reflect back and say
yes
we acknowledge there was changes to be
need to be done and it's been done and
just give that person time and i'm sure
we will see the results we all want to
see leroy logan thank you very much for
speaking to us sharing your views with
us laurel logan there former
superintendent at met police